good morning good day and good evening
to all welcome and thank you for
attending the second
webinar in part two of our webinar mini
series
hosted by the immunoassay platform
solutions team at milliporesigma
my name is andy arena i'll be the
moderator for today
for today's presentation entitled high
throughput biomarker profiling for
immuno-oncology research
using milliplex assays it is my job to
ensure that we make the most out of your
time today
we have two speakers for you yani common
with millipore sigma
and jenny kernitzer from bristol myers
squibb
before we get started here a few things
that everyone needs to know first is the
timing
we have allotted 60 minutes for today's
webinar this will be taken up largely by
the presentation but we have 15 minutes
saved at the end for q a
and that brings me to the second point
to further enhance your webinar
experience
we've set up some interactives
throughout the presentation
first is the question submission this
will be ongoing throughout the
presentation
make sure to keep an eye on the
questions being submitted and you can
upload questions that you like
at the end of the presentation we will
work our way through some of these
with priority on questions with the
highest number of likes
and don't worry if you ask a question
late and it doesn't get any likes or a
few likes
we have a team of 10 field scientists
that are quarantined in their homes
itching
to answer every last one of these i
promise we have the time to get to all
of them
and since you're registered with us
today we can follow up this presentation
with the document providing the answers
to questions asked
we will not include any names only the q
and a
so please ask away and then second is
the live polling
these won't be hard hitting questions
but keep an eye out for the classroom
icon
in the top right of the presentation
that indicates that a poll is coming
on that slide and here is a practice
poll that we can take right now
who was working from home today
i know i am my family of five are here
in the house we're staying productive
and positive but looking forward to
better days for sure
so please answer we will leave the polls
open for a minute or two
or until all the answers slow down and
no longer come in
we have three more polls planned for
today so again keep an eye out for the
symbol in the top right corner of the
slides
and finally as i said before my name is
andy
and just before i turn this over to the
speakers i want to point out that we do
did have a third webinar originally
scheduled for this coming thursday
the topic was homebrew development
converting milliplex assays to our
ultrasensitive
single molecule counting technology
fortunately we had to postpone this
presentation
and we are working on confirming a new
date so please stay tuned
now without further ado please welcome
our first speaker yannick
is one of our immuno assay platform
specialists he's based in brooklyn new
york
and he has spent the last nine years at
millipore sigma supporting our
immunoassay technologies and products in
new jersey
jan's presentation will focus on immune
immune checkpoint proteins and their
role
in immuno oncology research take it away
yan
hello everybody and uh welcome to our
webinar thank you for the introduction
andy
and uh yep very much like andy my family
is at home as well
itching to get out and be out in the
field but for the time being we're
grateful that you have the time to spend
with us today
and uh for our mini introduction
we'll be talking about the immune
oncology landscape and the panel that we
have
that is being used by jenny and her team
live
thank you of course we couldn't do
without a little bit of marketing
and we wanted to remind everybody that
our
miliplex portfolio is uh the largest on
the market and is always growing
we have panels for just about every
species out there
as a matter of fact the one picture
that's missing here is coming soon and
there'll be the ovine or the sheep panel
and within those species of course we
have
panels that are specific to different
research areas
should you need them and slide please
okay but for the focus of today and for
a big topic in in the lives of
researchers of course cancer is
a big one and we know that there are
generally 10 hallmarks of cancer
we know that generally our immune system
is a very
does a very good job of protecting us
and
anytime a cell kind of gets out of
control we have a whole team of immune
cells that will put them right back
where they belong
and everything is basically nice and
happy
however tumor cells get clever
and they try to escape those controls
and over time we have learned that their
immune checkpoint proteins
that are expressed on the surface of
both presenting cells and immune cells
that interact to either enhance the
response
or downplay that response and slide
please
so a lot of research has been done over
the last few years
where we've learned which molecules
interact with the immune system
and how they actually interact what are
the responses
are they inhibitory are they enhancing
are they co-stimulatory
now generally we know that all of these
are membrane-bound
and we know that there are cytokines
that are
soluble molecules that are flowing in
the system that
interact with all the cells to have
these interactions happen
however during the cancer environment
or the tumor environment whether it's in
the body or in the micro environment
itself
a lot of these molecules of these
checkpoint or inhibitor molecules
can be cleaved and if they are cleaved
we now have the opportunity to measure
their presence and perhaps get a little
bit more insight
into the disease state
why please and with knowing that disease
state
it improves our understanding and our
knowledge and perhaps improves our
understanding on how to treat
said disease so military sigma has come
up with a panel
that we call the immuno-oncology
checkpoint
protein panel one it is a 17-plex panel
that includes are popular
or common immune check molecules that
have become solubilized
now some of these are of course called
stimulatory like cd aedc
sticks some of them are inhibitory and
like the currently popular
pd1 pdl1 and pdl2
uh one thing that i would like to
highlight about this particular panel
is that we have gone to lengths to make
sure
that while there is um
homologous regions among all three
molecules of pd1
pdl1 and pdo2 we made sure that there is
no
antibody crosstalk across reactivity and
all the detection of these
is absolutely individual and actually
correct
why please
so here's a representation of the
various standard curves that are
included
in this panel um you can see that
they're
biologically relevant of course the
sensitivity and the min
dc is represented we can detect
i would suspect almost all the states
more it is possible that some of the
healthy states may not be detectable but
that is something that we'll have to i
guess figure out as research goes on and
jenny will talk more to it
but what i wanted to highlight here
specifically is
we have made sure that our intra essay
in inter acid precision
is very good that way your continuous
studies
and your ongoing research is all
relatable to the previous
experiments why please
so what does this allow us to do
this allows us to look at different
disease models
and paint kind of like a fingerprint
with these molecule measurements to
understand
what happens for example we can take
serum levels in the breast cancer
samples
and measure these immune checkpoint
inhibitor molecules
and we can see that some are elevated
versus normal some are not
cd80 is undetectable in this particular
case
but it doesn't necessarily mean that all
cancer
will present exactly the same profile
so if we look at the sepsis panel which
is next applied
this profile is a little different now
what happens here
we know that the sepsis by itself
provides a an immune suppression and
seeing here there are elevated immune
suppressor molecules
that are solubilized we can understand
better how sepsis works
is so far so good i hope
so next slide well it also happens
that within a given cancer disease we
know that there are different stages for
various panels
for various cancers of course so
here we took an example of three
different breast cancer lines
and had them in conditioned media and
measured the
release of these immune checkpoint
molecules in the media
and you can see that among the three
different lines
they have a slightly different
presentation of the uh
of the checkpoints now is this related
to the particular stage that the breast
cancer is in
quite possibly but this gives us a
better picture and better understanding
on what is going on within each stage of
the disease progression
by please and likewise we can look at
other disease situations
so here is a sample where we're looking
at colon cancer
versus healthy control patients and we
could see that things like
stem pd1 tlrs are elevated
versus the healthy controls where these
molecules are
very low but not detectable within the
serum
and that tells us that these um the
cells within the colon cancer
trying to escape their control by
bleeding or solubilizing
these particular molecules
lie please
now the picture of the immune checkpoint
inhibitor of the pedal itself
is just a a nice little snippet of the
information that we get
and for that of course we present you
with complementary panels that can be
used in concert with
the immune checkpoint inhibitor panel
for example we have the high sensitivity
or cd8 panel
we have the cytokine receptor panel and
we have the th17
panel which all have similar but
more specialized ideas about looking
into
other cytokines chemokine signal release
that would work in concert with the
information we collect
from the immune checkpoint inhibitor and
so we can combine together the
information that we gather from one
panel
with the inflammatory or with biomarkers
and get a complete picture of a disease
state
instead of like in the good old days
where we would look for the western blot
and have just
one particular gene and that would be
our aha moment
now we get to see the big picture with
all of these
pieces of information put together
um
of course sorry
of course the questions don't end there
and uh coming to a laboratory near you
soon hopefully once the pandemic is over
the plane is for the summer
we will have a sequel to the checkpoint
inhibitor panel
which will be panel 2. this will be a 31
flex
that contains some of your other
favorites
and um contain molecules that
maybe you were looking to find like cd40
ligand
perhaps ox40 perhaps make a and b brands
and b some of the popular ones
and this will make a bigger picture even
more detailed
now i understand there's a new poll
currently live
feel free to answer but in the meantime
slide please
i turn this back to andy and thank you
very much for listening to me for the
last few minutes
well thank you yan okay while you're
answering the poll
move on i'm very pleased to welcome our
second speaker
jenny kernitzer is an immunobiologist at
bms in princeton new jersey
while at bms she's focused on small
molecule
and biologics drug discovery in the
immuno-oncology space
it's work focused particularly in the
area of t cell checkpoint inhibitors
and myeloid cell-mediated immune
suppression
one of our current responsibilities is
overseeing the biomarker profiling team
which provides high-throughput sample
testing to the entire bms research
community
jenny's talk will focus how the luminex
platform
is used to support very diverse early
discovery research at bms
the focus on immuno oncology
applications and some case studies for
the milliplex checkpoint panel
that jan just described jenny the floor
is yours thank you very much jan
and thank you very much andy um for the
introduction
and the invitation um to talk about our
research at bms
so i'm going to spend the next 25
minutes or so with you
to share how we use biomarker profiling
to advance
our research at bms
i will introduce our biomarker platform
and the role that biomarkers play
specifically in the early stage i o
discovery space
i also want to share some experiences
that we have specifically with the
milliplex assays
and show you some case studies of how we
apply them
finally i want to leave you with an
outlook of our future plans for the
biomarker profiling space
my group as annie has said is based in
new jersey
and we serve as a central biomarker
profiling hub
for the early stage discovery needs at
bms
we routinely work with and receive
samples from all of our u.s research
sites which
are in new jersey massachusetts
california and washington
as well as from our international
collaborators
around the world
in order to facilitate high throughput
analysis
we have established a semi-automated and
miniaturized process that is based on
the xmap technology
we run all samples that we receive in a
custom
in-house developed 384-well process
which facilitates 75 cost savings and
increases sample capacity at least
four-fold
while also reducing the sample volume
needed for profiling significantly
we also make heavy use of a number of
automation platforms
liquid handlers and workstations for
example to support the consolidation of
samples from submitted sample plates
into master essay plates
or the steps of sample washing for
example
we then have a dedicated fleet of reader
instruments
that when we are not quarantined in our
homes
run pretty much 24 7 to process these
samples
finally our entire process is built on a
custom
internal i.t platform that allows our
customers to submit their profiling
requests
online help us with inventory and study
data management
and support the generation of customized
reports
for the different research communities
that we work with
my team currently runs biomarker panels
for five different species
human mouse red dog and sinnoh
and we support projects from the early
exploratory to the early clinical phases
the wheel on the right hand side is
intended to give you a flavor for the
types of studies that we routinely run
one category is mechanism of action
studies where we
profile samples generated from cell
culture
for example co-cultures of tumors and
immune cells or
ex-vivo stimulated preparations of
primary immune cells in whole blood
another big focus area are pkpd or
efficacy studies
for pre-clinical animal models such as
syndinate or genetically engineered
tumor mouse models
but also rodent models used for fibrosis
cardiovascular or autoimmune disease
a third and ever increasing bucket of
our work
falls in the realm of toxicity study
including exploratory talk studies
for new investigational drug
applications
things we look for often with the
appropriate analyte panels
include cytokine storm and immune
activation
as well as liver and kidney injury
and the last category that we work on
falls in the realm of exploratory
biomarker identification
and patient stratification where we
profile biobank samples including those
from internal clinical trials
as well as various disease population
samples that we typically source from
our academic collaboration partners
including the corresponding normal
healthy volunteer controls
in order to be able to support this
weight range of study types
we need a very broad coverage of analyte
panels for the different purposes in
therapeutic areas
we currently have over 600 analytes in
active use
and around 60 of those are in various
forms of milliport milliplex panels
we also have an ever-growing list of new
analytes in development
which can either mean that we are
working to miniaturize existing panels
to add to our capabilities
or to develop completely new analytes
mostly through a very very fruitful
collaboration with the
miliportine the different panels that we
use are broadly classified
into innate and adaptive immunity
heart failure fibrosis and toxicity
the immunology and soluble checkpoint
panels are the ones i will mostly be
focusing
on the remainder of the talk as our
focus was on immuno oncology
i had mentioned that a lot of our remit
and biomarker profiling
at bms is on high throughput and as such
we have optimized the workflows to be
able to handle up to 2000 samples each
week
with sample requirements between 5 and
20 microliters per individual panel
a very large fraction of the sample
types that we typically deal with
are serum plasma or supernatants and
lysates from either cell cultures or
tissues
we do however also occasionally work
with more exotic matrices such as
aside blister fluid synovial fluid
bronchoalveolar lavage
or increasing the urine we have been
building this platform over the last few
years and its use across the bms
research community has really taken off
to date we have profiled more than 235
000 samples for
170 different discovery programs which
resulted in more than 10 million data
points
this large-scale profiling brings its
own challenges
in data management which i will touch
upon a little bit later
now i want to switch gears a little bit
and focus
specifically on our immuno oncology
support
of the roughly 47 000 samples that we
handled last year
almost half of them shown in red came
from immuno-oncology
as you can see in the breakdown on the
right the majority of the samples are
from human origin
followed by mouse and spino on average
each individual study that we run
has about 70 samples but the range can
be very wide from as few as 10 samples
to as many as 800 samples in a
particular study
similarly we profile a mean of 41
cytokines for particular samples
again the range is way wide from as
little as 14 which would be an
individual panel
all the way up to 100 which would be a
number of different panels
consequently the average number of
panels we run per sample is about three
we have certainly seen over the last
year or two
that the demand for broader profiling
more analytes per sample is ever
increasing
which is in line with more and more
analytes becoming available for
different pathways
now you might ask yourself why we expend
such a lot of effort to investigate
soluble biomarkers in general and
cytokines in particular for our io
research
it might become clearer when looking at
cancer as essentially the result
of a dysregulated immune system as an
ira mellman's and then trans cancer
immunity cycle
shown here where every step of
successful tumor eradication
is dependent on cytokines as the master
regulators
from tumor antigen presentation to the
activation and priming of different
relevant immune cells to trafficking
those cells to a site of malignancy
and finally infiltration recognition and
destruction of the tumor cells
we have long known that cytokines play
dual roles in tumorigenesis
they contribute to tumor formation for
example by promoting pathogenic
inflammation and tissue damage or
invasion
metastasis and angiogenesis but also
play
key roles in preventing tumor formation
or resolving early stage malignancies
understanding this intricate balance of
the immune system's master regulators is
key in developing
successful i o drugs and the first step
is understanding which molecules are
present at what stage of cancer
development
indeed cytokines themselves are also
interesting therapeutic
options for cancers this graphic
from a 2019 review
shows which one of the cytokines have or
are currently being investigated in
clinical trials
from interference to dncs f and various
interleukins
indeed interferon alpha and ielts ii are
already approved treatments for
hairstyle leukemia
and melanoma and renal cancer
respectively
and both of those treatment mechanisms
um
basically rely on broad immune
stimulation
with this outside role outside role of
soluble biomarkers including cytokines
chemokines and checkpoints
it is probably not surprising that we
have a fairly large selection of
analytes and routine use for our i o
focus project here i am showing the 133
analytes and their corresponding panels
that we use for human profiling of io
samples
at bms we have similar somewhat smaller
selections that we use for mountain
signal studies
all of these panels that i'm showing
here are based of
existing milliplex panels and i want to
use the next couple slides to show you
some of our experiences with those
panels
so when we do profiling for io samples
we don't just use the checkpoint panel
typically it's usually a combination of
various different panels depending on
what type of question of innate or
adaptive immunity
we actually want to answer how much
volume we have for a particular sample
and what sort of sensitivity do we need
to get the data
so my first example for experience with
the milliplex
panels goes back to the sensitivity and
quantification in the high sensitivity
melatex panels
the sensitivity in particular the
lower limit of quantification are
critical aspects for a lot of the
cytochrome biomarkers
as a large fraction of those biomarkers
are only found in very very low
concentrations
in particularly when using unstimulated
samples
or healthy controls we have frequently
struggled with detecting
certain biomarkers reliably diff in
different sample types
let alone properly quantify them
that is why we were very eager to adopt
the high sensitivity panels when they
became available
and are always on the lookout for new
high sensitivity analytes being added to
this
selection the tables that you can show
on the slide
on the left for human on the right for
mouse
shows a comparison of the llq the lower
limit of quantification
compared between the milliplex normal
regular sensitivity panels that we
initially started using
and the newer high sensitivity panels
the lloqs in our case are determined by
the fit
of the respective analyte standard curve
under our specific asset conditions
as you can see most of the analytes have
a
vastly improved lloq in some case very
significantly
by 50 or more fold some analytes for
which this has been especially helpful
are il-10 il-12 p70 il4
5 and 6 where we routinely use these
high sensitivity analytes to better get
a better understanding of our samples
now the llq is a particular function of
how we run our assays and how we run our
standard curves
so your individual mileage depending on
how you run your assets may vary but in
our hands they have performed
very very well
my next example for working with the
milliplex panels comes to adopting the
checkpoint panel one
that jan had introduced so when the
checkpoint
milliplex panels or checkpoint luminex
panels in general
became became available on the market
we set out to figure out which ones
behaved well under our particular assay
condition
and these are of course of c used when
we profile
patient samples for patient
stratification
so this 17 analyze soluble checkpoint
panel from millipex
is now in pretty wide use as it includes
the key markers like pd1 pdo1
pdl2 and lag 3 and we are certainly very
excited to later this year test
checkpoint panel 2 as well when we
originally
wanted to adopt checkpoint panels we
wanted to see how they performed
as we have done a large variety of work
on targeting checkpoint molecules in
house of bms
we have a number of recombinant proteins
available
to test a particular kid's performance
exactly this type of data is shown on
this slide in heatmap format
and what i'm showing is the raw
fluorescence intensities from this
particular
experiment across the x-axis you can see
the different analytes or signal
channels and bead regions
along the y-axis are the respective
standards that come with the kit at the
top
followed by the recombinant proteins pd1
pdl1 and pdl2 that we spiked into the
samples
you see that as expected across the top
each standard produces a nice dose
response
dependent signal in it with its
respective bead
going down the list then you'll notice
that in our hands the specificity of the
kit is excellent
each recombinant protein only produces a
signal in the channel
or with the bead where we would expect
it with everything else
looks like background giving us
confidence in this particular reagent
at the time we were also evaluating
other kits
that are available in the market and
here i'm showing an example of one that
doesn't
behave quite as well same concept as
before a slightly different analyte
composition in the kit
the kit standard by and large
behave well and the control proteins
produce
strong signals with their respective
beads in our condition
however under our acid conditions with
this kit we also observed significant
cross reactivity with sterile beads
which are kind of the blue arrows where
i tried to highlight where we got a
signal where we wouldn't
expect it which of course then means
that we ultimately can't reliably
quantify
um the sample um with regards to the
individual checkpoint amount
now for the next section of my talk
i want to focus on some key applications
of biomarker profiling
in our i o discovery research pipeline
and i see there is a poll online so
please go ahead and answer if you would
like
and i also want to share on the
following slides from case studies to
give you a flavor
of how we use cytokine profiling data
and multiplex data
to progress individual projects the case
studies basically
and compares three different flavors of
experiments that we support
first are in vitro cell models such as
profiling the signatures of primary
immune cells or tumor cells as well as
co-cultures
we use these experiments typically very
early in a project during the target
validation
phase the second type of experiments are
in the pre-clinical or in vivo group
where we profile tumor models in animals
either in vivo or ex-vivo
and also analyze samples from
exploratory truck studies
often performed in cinemalgous monkeys
for a particular drug candidate
and the third and final category
encompasses all types of patient samples
these are typically the samples that are
the most precious and where we
perform the most possible broad analyses
in the early stages of an io discovery
project we use a number of complex
cellular models to analyze a particular
target or compound's behavior
one of these models that we use widely
is the co-culture
of genetically engineered primary t
cells
which express a known antigen-specific t
cell receptor
with a matched tumor cell presenting the
cognitive antigen
on the mhc molecules that way we can
co-culture these two cells
and measure antispin specific activation
and ultimately tumor cell killing
by the t cells of the tumor an
example of that is shown in the pictures
on the right
where the tumor cells are labeled with a
red dye and we measure cell death
with a green dye staining apoptotic
cells
that then externalize nxn5
and the top picture basically shows the
absence
of antigen in the co culture which means
the t cell cannot recognize the tumor
cell
there is no activation and the tumor
cells basically overgrow the well
in the bottom case we have added the
antigen to the co
culture and now the tumor cells can be
recognized by the antigen specific t
cell be activated and killed which means
during the co-culture you can
actively monitor the lysis and the
killing
and basically the disappearance of the
red tumor cells
and the increase of clustering of dead
cells in those green clusters that i'm
showing there the right hand side
on the bottom also t cell activation
results in a very strong increase in t
cell specific cytokine production so we
frequently use the
milliplex t cell panel to quantify those
changes in a higher throughput
and that is an example that i am showing
here
where the whole concept of this
particular project
is to turn a cold tumor
that has no antigen presentation
into a hot tumor that presents antigen
and then enables antigen-specific t-cell
activation
and cytokine production and as i have
mentioned we use the t-cell panel shown
on the bottom right
very widely to run these types of
experiment and we model this particular
project
by co-culturing different types of tumor
cells with the antigen specific t
cells with or without molecules that
act as epigenetic modulators which we
hope will induce
antigen expression and this is
data from the actual experiment shown
in the heat map in the middle and the
way i have represented the data is
as a log twofold change of the
individual cytokines measured
over the unstimulated control and in
this case unstimulated control
means a tumor t cell co-culture where no
antigen
is present so no t cell activation
occurs
across the bottom you see three
different
flavors of tumor cells that we have used
let me start on the left hand side where
we used
a wild type tumor cell
and we basically have a positive control
we load that tumor cell with the
cognitive antigen
which leads to strong t cell activation
and ultimately tumor lysis which is
indicated
by the green column of
numbers on the first hand side of the on
the most left hand side of the table
so this basically means that the t cells
were very very strongly activated
and lyse the tumor cells and
proliferated and produced
all of those um different molecules
including
um for example granzyme
or interfering gamma which are key for
mediating t cell effector forms
then instead of actually providing the
antigen to the co
culture we instead treated the tumor
cells with epigenetic modulator
modulator 102 to see if interfering with
several of these pathways we could
achieve the same effect so
induce antigen expression
in a tumor that normally does not
express this antigen
and as you can see for the epigenetic
modulator number one
we actually do get a good response it
seems like the
tumor cell is now after treatment able
to be recognized
um by the t cell and from other data we
know that it does indeed
now express um the antigen and present
it on its mhc molecule
epigenetic modulator number two on the
other hand
didn't really work that well
we wanted to make sure that this
observed behavior was indeed due to the
tumor cell antigen presentation pathway
which needs a whole machinery from gene
expression to protein production
and processing of those proteins to the
eventual loading of the antigenic
fragment
onto the cellular mhc models before a t
cell receptor can recognize the tumor
cell
therefore for this project we created
some crispr
knockouts of key proteins in those
pathways
and those are the other two cell lines
you see across the bottom in purple and
in blue
we made a beta 2 mko the better 2 mko is
an essential component of the mhc
complex on the salt surface
so in the absence of this protein no
functional mhc
complex can be formed and the cell is
not present it is not capable of
presenting any antigens whether they
come from outside or inside of the cell
the second is the temp1 ko so tap1 is an
essential transporter
for intracellular antigen processing and
antigen loading onto the mhc
so in the absence of this protein those
particular cells
are not able to present newly expressed
near antigens but are expected to have a
functional mhc
on the surface and indeed our cytokine
data
using the antigen loaded control confirm
what we expected the tumor cells without
a functional mhc at all the beta2mko
no longer induces t cell activations
even when we load the antigen externally
however the type 1ko still has an mhc
and is therefore able to perform like
the wild type
in both case our epigenetic modulators
don't work anymore to the deficiencies
in the antigen presentation pathway
which together with other data gave us
confidence that the
approach is promising so this is an
example where we use complex cellular
models and routine profiling of t-cell
activation markers
to better understand the mechanisms and
validate targets
in io
my next case studies comes more from the
mouse in vivo work that we do
specifically from an osotopic transplant
model of pancreatic cancer
here the specific question was if
radiation therapy
a standard of care approach can enhance
immunotherapy
efficacy of pd-1 inhibitors or
combinations of pd1 and ido inhibitors
ultimately the data revealed that
survival was improved by a combination
of radiation and anti-pd-1
but that ideo combinations were not
useful
but that the efficacy of the p1 activity
correlated with the systemic
interference gamma response
that we monitored by multiplex
phytochrome profiling
as my third example i want to give you a
flavor for how we use
phytochrome profiling to evaluate the
toxicity risks of our later stage
molecules before filing an ind
in this particular example a bms
molecule was given in increasing doses
group 1 is the control group and group 2
and 4
2 through 4 received the drug twice a
week apart and we received serum samples
for cytokine profiling at different time
points
from just before the first dose until
about two weeks after the last dose
here we assess the total of 44 different
cytokines in
two different thinner specific panels
i have just chosen five relevant ones
for the line graph and
each line in the graph represents an
individual monkey
we observed a dose-dependent transient
increase in inflammatory cytokines that
peaks three to six hours after dosing
and returns to baseline within 24 hours
we also saw that the second dose doesn't
cause the same magnitude of effect
together with other data that was
collected from the
study we could conclude that the
molecule was well tolerated
and did not cause a cytokine storm which
was a particular concern
for this particular mechanism of action
of this molecule
because we could also from in vitro data
we had previously generated figure out
that these transient cytokine inductions
that we see
are most likely on mechanism and on
target
in my last example i want to talk to you
very briefly about our work
with patient samples and this is where
we most broadly apply the checkpoint
panel one that jan
had introduced when we obtain these
types of patient samples we typically
perform very very broad profiling
as much typically as sample volumes
permit
often for a hundred or more analytes
including the checkpoint panel
um so the heat map exemplifies
an example of what such data could look
like
those aggregate several hundred serum
samples by different tumor types
which shows clear differences in the
checkpoint molecules detected
ultimately the goal is to build a
sufficiently large database that allows
us to identify
predictive biomarker signatures when
linked to patient phenotypic
or treatment data and another focus for
us is also
performing longitudinal studies on
treatment
particularly with ntp1 to investigate
the response to treatment or the
development of resistance mechanism
and their impact on the respective
biomarker signatures
further what we also frequently do is
use
explants to evaluate individual
treatments and treatment combos
and with biomarker data the multiplex
luminex data is typically one key
readout of those
types of studies
with that i was i hope i was able to
give you a flavor for how we use
multiplex biomarker profiling
in io discovery at bmf and i want to
finish with an
outlook on our current and future focus
areas
an ever ongoing effort is the expansion
of coverage
so adding new panels of analytes to the
platform
or developing new analytes all together
in close collaboration with millipore
we also have a growing need for custom
disease-specific panels
to support targeted biomarker studies
and we also are always very interested
in trying to
consolidate and merge individual panels
wherever possible
to both reduce workloads and the volumes
of sample that are needed
finally we also spend a lot of effort in
two
closely related areas data analytics and
data integration
i have shown you that we profile tens of
thousands of samples a year across a
wide variety of experimental design
with that comes a strong need for data
management
and more importantly meta data
management so all the data can be
applied for the right as possible use so
we are constantly trying to optimize
our data registration and database
models or build new systems to handle
these types of data
this is also key in facilitating
enhanced bioinformatics methods for data
analysis
as well as efforts to implement machine
learning
particularly for generating disease
predictive biomarker signatures
finally biomarker data becomes much more
informative when it can be overlaid with
other data types generated from the same
types of studies
such as sequencing of phenotyping data
for example
so we are trying to build structures
that enable to do that more easily
and lastly an effort that we have
ongoing
focuses on new technologies that allows
investigating the cytokine profile of a
single cell
as we know immune cells in particular
show very heterogeneous responses to
treatment
and ultimately we want to marry that
single cell data to the bulk biomarker
data that we routinely produce from the
luminex profiling
with that i want to thank you for your
attention
and acknowledge and particularly the bms
cytokine team
especially melissa yard and nathan
cheadle who are the engines of this
platform and keep the sample and data
flowing on a day-by-day basis
and we are also indebted to all of our
bms collaborators both
those who enable us to physically run
all the instruments that we need
as well as the partners in the
individual therapeutic
areas who supply us with the samples and
i also want to acknowledge our very
strong partners
at miliport particularly jan and shane
who we meet with frequently and
non-pandemic times
as well as brook who supports our ever
expanding list of requests
for new analytes and with that um
thank you very much again
and i'll hand it back over to andy
all right thank you jenny thank you
jenny and jan for this great
presentation